[Music]
welcome back to another chapter of dirty
Rd chapter ten and also welcome back
Jake Decker thank you it's good to have
you back seems like I missed a lot dirty
our teas looking very different he looks
a little too clean so we have a lot to
kind of do in order to regain the true
nature of dirty Rd so last episode if
you caught it on chapter 9 we celebrated
the New Year by looking a little fancy
set off some fireworks killing the mayor
and having him join us on top of the
mountaintop where we then or did we so
that's right the mayor is still alive
because unfortunately we use cheats and
with cheats enabled you can't save so we
have to get our revenge and we have to
kill the mayor because that mayor sucks
so that's what we're doing this episode
we're also gonna name this horse I think
that might be one of the first things we
do because we have to name all of our
horses and we didn't really get to it
last time so we lost three horses last
time we lost wrecked one galosh wreck -
we lost Shrek the halls so this I think
is Shrek the third Shrek the third or
shrek forever after right we want to
change clothes first right we want to
change clothes first and get out of
these jumps these unknowingly ugly fancy
clothes we need to get back and regain
our strength as Arthur morgan dirty
already excuse me
so one of the things as we now are
putting on the role Jake as a hitman
mm-hmm we need we need some some slick
dark clothing I think that's pretty good
I feel like that that seems like a dirty
arty bit and then gets a jacket like
this yeah okay oh so I totally forgot I
wanted I went out and found a really
great mask to wear oh yeah we'll save
that for a little bit later though right
yeah we'll save that for a little bit
later sir would you like
boots or shoes no thank you no we're
good ooh the light the low-calorie yeah
these these are hitman gloves right here
all right now we got a name our horse a
part of me wants to steer away from the
Shrek movies all right
that's that's me personally I'm okay
with calling them Shrek dirty
make that make that tail as braided as f
oh you're the type who likes to stand
out huh I bought some horse Reviver
because I'm sick and tired of killing
houses like injuring them and then
having to put him down and there should
be up on that balcony right there to
left but he's not there but I think this
guy's talking she I think so too
I think this is the mayor's brother Oh
what's this I feel like killing good god
oh we got a lot of witnesses we should
have been wearing masks all along okay
if I'm running yes skip to morning and
we'll see if the mayor's in there dad
what are you saying what'd you say about
our masks howdy
yep know what we're doing again yeah we
have found a mayor of strawberry this is
the ceremonial assassination and sword
yeah Oh mayor damn no mayor still over
there check if he's inside again please
what do you want
I don't know but this this mayor is very
elusive we kind of had the same problem
last time stop it Morgan hates cats very
already hates cats
okay I love this town now this is Rob
this is my kind of town right now I'm
Lou Mayer dirty RV
this town sucks I hate this I hate this
town let's go - lets go - Valentine they
love us there they do
oh come on dirty yeah you got the Popo
on you okay we know you must have
someone else I'm sorry
Pigman oh no he's down there
I'm Raccoon man you must be looking for
my brother
big crazy [ __ ] yeah I bet that way that
sounds like Pigman he did all that oh my
gosh Gilda into our town ate all your
food let me ask you was he carrying some
kind of sword yeah I can see I carry an
axe you know if I see him what's your
address I gotta come right to you yeah
he hates the mayor huh I don't remember
telling you that oh look an eagle
that's too good dude you would have lost
every tooth in ouch
come on dirty I don't know mammy revive
revive errs we have level you'd only
carry three okay yeah just the class
ticket ah classic loadout perfect I
don't think you've ever done it so
perfectly perfect toss this guy didn't
even notice no he noticed he's just
afraid hold up now hold up
I want Mickey Regency none I just want
to talk stop
I hate the horse something bloody where
are you going I just want to talk
let the murderin begin time to get
sneaky best talk to the foreman we can
use you right now I know how to hide my
brother big man can brand the other
correct I like I like how dirty Artie's
darker personality is coming for which
big man his big man he's got a second
split personality
hi I'm Pigman nice to meet you nicely
done don't you come to a no driscoll
cats looking for trouble feeding we're
looking for trouble my friends Pigman
gives his regards
should you wait until dark again for for
enter Valentine yeah
maybe our do evening maybe I think and
we stock the town and we find our like
last victim I think our victims should
be the sheriff okay
cuz he's always around right I did the
sheriff or it could be those guys behind
the that I always dive off yeah let's
kill them too
but I just thought of a dirty artis
calling card mmm what oh you'll see I'm
the hero valentown deserves
yeah really really no wonder there oh
yes there's some time I always need to
follow a guy act normal perfect my
calling card
Oh cops that way your calling card as a
can of beads
well depends what I have a can of
whatever oh it's so brilliant so leave
go over the body
simmer down let's just see how he ties
we could we could kill someone run away
yeah come back and at least it and then
oh look at that guy and then
occasionally oh let me remember his face
okay alright
oh my god we'll come back yeah take off
take off your mask we'll go back into
town be like I heard it was a Pigman
around here
[Music]
SiC no one thought look Jeremiah kidney
beans it's the pig man again isn't it
tell everyone to lock their doors
tonight round up the boys we're gonna
hunt the pig man ladies and gentlemen
you guys are you all here
to let you know of a pig man on the
loose if you see anyone wearing a pig
mask and/or has a load of cat food run
our general store owners are gonna need
to watch out if someone comes in fitting
that description buying cans of food
yeah alert your local sheriff
even if said gentleman is buying I don't
know say two dozen cans of food you let
us know oh that's freaking mask I'm out
of the thing but I'm still a witness I
wonder if I just pissed off the town I
did but we can still sneak into the town
[Music]
[Music]
it's not cool you put your whole pig
snout into the can found our killer okay
and the rooftops and prowl so discreet
so ninja like you look a little hungry
you have my scraps here peaches you'd
expect maybe the local police to start
putting an APB out for wearing pig pig
mask oh my god
stealth your way right behind him so bad
at hiding
[Music]
Oh No that's it
you lost dirty horsey this is some
fugitive ass yeah I was pretty cool
wasn't cool like get away another way
yeah yeah dirty [ __ ] she's dead
man that was three revives - I thought
we'd get at least through an episode or
a chapter about that just one second
there talk to you one second he might be
still alive oh you think so yeah I know
a good way to check gotta hide the
bodies got out of the body's gotta make
sure it was a kill is so sick I can't
believe he's arrived that can I hope
even better imagine if that was your
getaway into the river that was a bit
monumental oh look I made it
Oh dirty horse he's still alive oh oh my
god all right here we go there's a horse
perfect this guy's yeah put a little
roadblock hmm hold up just a sec oh it's
a good pillow yeah it does
I like one room with my wife apologize
here is my peace offering Who am I feels
like I'm home again sleepy sleep
tomorrow's gonna burn this night it's
gonna be a big one okay so he's in he's
in the same spot he's doing exact same
thinks up yeah I think you should do the
exact same thing again you know it what
if I do the same thing and run around to
the other side and try to get on from
behind yeah yeah get them and kill them
like right here mmhmm yeah ding I just
fixed that Oh perfect the clean kill
we're good
that shotgun or that that sawed-off
shotgun has a real nice sound to it so I
forgot where I was for a second totally
spaced - he was killing Reagan who are
you chef Lee I think you should flee I
think you should then come back and get
a drink at the bar and if they don't
serve you then you get drunk and proceed
again oh just getting up Jimmy once I
know
maybe I can get him to follow me to the
to live in Rock Slide I should eat some
cheese or before get them all up here
there's one down there but is this it
this is it right here if it's not it
we're just dying if that is it Oh what
happened I looked away for a second I
think I hit someone totally to shoulder
checked you oh I was very great it
looked like a person I'd have to see it
again he knew what you were doing they
learned they should they saw your rock
slide feels they knew where you were up
to right by it try again yeah totally
[Laughter]
don't finesse that time there they are T
come on dance right just kind of
plankton
I want my horse back but much okay but
oh it's offensive would let me butter a
muncher butter munch all right we got
ourselves a horse
come on butter be a good girl
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is so scary it's like dripping all
right well let's get drunk and call it
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
well that's gonna do it for this chapter
of dirty already thank you all for
watching before we go and take off we
wanted to oh yeah I acknowledge people
who sent us some of their dirty Artie's
from their own saves hashtag show us
your RT this is a very nice photo from
Barry Stewart classic using the the
animal hat the animal than where it's a
great pose Arthur's Dave he steals from
the rich and Rob's the poor that's very
dirty aren't you yeah
sounds about right this this is one of
my favorites
bright yellow chaps definitely really
see the mud you can really see the mud
with those chaps but you know this
remind me of is the boy from where the
wild things are like all grown up he's
great Ross Finny here has a gangster
straight-up a Guy Ritchie movie
definitely very classy and lastly a
spicy man five nine one that's a good
one I like that's a good shot of him
smoked in - yeah right this is this is
like maybe the most dirty arty right
here I think though next week we're
gonna try to get dirty Artie's beard max
right I think that is gonna be the goal
you have to go to a later point in the
story but we're gonna get there and
that's grind through it a lot of been
asking when are we gonna get his beard
to max length and I've seen the max
length and holy gosh it's pretty funny
it's pretty incredible so we'll do that
next week thank you guys for watching
thank you Jake and y'all take care
[Music]